[Music]
27 years
[Music]
[Applause]
15 majors
and five back surgeries after turning
pro
[Applause]
the world's most popular golfer is now
the newest member of the three comma
club
when tiger's in town there's always a
crowd
[Music]
triumph
injury
scandal
failure and triumph again have filled
the years since tiger woods first
stalked the fairways at the 1997 masters
but through it all the 46 year old woods
has maintained his supremacy as one of
the top earning athletes in the world
raking in over 1.7 billion dollars in
salary endorsements and other income
over the course of his 27-year career
more than anyone else we've tracked
forbes now estimates his net worth to be
at least one billion dollars making him
one of just two active athletes to
achieve billionaire status along with
nba superstar lebron james michael
jordan the only other athlete
billionaire didn't hit 10 digits until
after he retired thanks to a well-timed
investment in the nba's charlotte
hornets less than 10 percent of wood's
career earnings and net worth come from
golf winnings he amassed his fortune
primarily through enormous endorsement
deals with brands like nike gatorade and
rolex he's also assembled an impressive
real estate portfolio including jupiter
florida and owns chunks of businesses
such as a restaurant called the woods
and an operator of upscale mini golf
courses with plans to expand nationwide
the center of attention even on the
practice range tiger woods preparing for
his second round with all the meticulous
attention to detail which has turned him
into what many believe is the best
player the world has ever seen woods's
impact on golf's tv ratings and purse
sizes cannot be overstated ten thousand
fans came to watch this year's
three-time major winner tame the green
at hyde park in the early 2000s
according to former cbs president neil
pilsen tv audiences would drop 30 to 50
percent when woods was not in contention
at a tournament this so-called tiger
effect contributed to pga tour winnings
nearly tripling between 1996 and 2008 a
stretch in which woods won 14 major
championships and that's helped the
off-field bucks get much bigger too
there's a long tradition spanning babe
ruth to arnold palmer to jordan of
athletes getting paid to endorse brands
but now the endorsement potential
stretches into the three commas thanks
to the amplifying effect of modern media
and technology
woods for example has over 10 million
followers across twitter instagram and
other social media platforms at his peak
woods was the most prolific athlete
endorser in history earning north of 100
million dollars per year off the course
he held the number one spot in forbes
highest paid athletes list for 10
consecutive years ending in 2012. even
now despite hardly ever teeing the ball
up over the past 12 months while
recovering from a serious car accident
woods collected 68 million dollars in
off-course income
enough to make him the 14th highest paid
athlete in the world
woods has used his status and earnings
to expand his business which now
includes a golf design business a live
events production company and a
restaurant
woods is also identified as a partner in
a spack announced in january
when combined with his real estate
holdings woods's wealth is secured
whether or not he ever swings a golf
club again
[Music]
you